I love everything there is about women's
beach volleyball
I want to walk away from these games
knowing that I performed at my highest
level my mom lets me borrow her cup as
long as I put gas in it
[Music]
in third grade our teachers asked us to
write down what we wanted to be most
when we grow up I wrote that I wanted to
be an invisible man who lives in the
ladies dressing room at JC Penney
but photographing women's beach
volleyball is a close second my pregame
rituals I like to sit quietly and pray
ah I like to clean the pipes if you know
what I mean do you think they know I
mean please dear Lord who art in heaven
let me see some boobies today if in your
infinite wisdom none of your business
mother shut up I'm a grown man with
legal rights and dignity there's nothing
quite like being at the Olympic Games
the lovely female volleyball players
leaping through the surf and you right
there in your car on a rooftop parking
deck a quarter mile away photographing
the action with a telephoto lens I love
sports you've got to get up pretty early
if you want that prime spot by the hole
in the fence I usually arrive on the
beach volleyball court three weeks
before the match even begins and I bury
myself in the sand then on the big day I
jump out boom get my shot hi girls
to see I wasn't sure if everyone
understood that cleaning the pipes is a
euphemism for shut up you old woman
I hate you Bob it's my time to shine
Oh